grandjean sûreté du québec cette voie
est celle d'un des répartiteurs qui
était en poste de 14 mars 2017
le soir du cafouillage de l'autoroute 13
oiseaux j'appelle travailleurs du québec
j'ai jamais vu une journée comme seule
fois que je vois pas plus il est à peine
21h la tempête ne fait que commencer
mais à la centrale n'est quelques
employés sont déjà débordés samedi le
jeu dans les enregistrements obtenus par
radio-canada on entend que les voix des
répartiteurs de la sûreté du québec
je vois par la voie des automobilistes
en détresse a été masquée pour des
raisons de vie privée j'ai pas de
solution des centaines d'automobilistes
sont prisonniers de leur voiture
certains le seront pendant 12 heures
pour finir à deux facteurs est resté
coincé pendant 11 heures
qu'est ce qui me frustre fait c'est que
quand même il y avait aucun espoir
la police est pas venu
j'ai même vu des ambiances qui passe à
pied rien personne a arrêté cette nuit
là la température ressentie est de moins
20 degrés celsius les unes après les
autres les voitures manque d'essence
d'abandonner si vous n'êtes pas dans
votre vie que toute la nuit des gens
appellent inquiet pour des proches
coincé sur l'autoroute le sujet c'est
pourquoi vous devez suivre donc à vous
d'avoir le trafic d'après gelée de 44
cents à combler nous et pour mourir de
froid dans son auto le krp nul et l'aide
tarde à arriver sur les lieux
mais la plante qui peut se traduire ou
en tout cas pas bhl de machines ok ok
moi je ne vois pas le plus vite compris
mais je ne garde pas d'abus large qui
posera vous au bout du fil une
automobiliste en larmes répartiteurs
tente de la rassurer
je ne sais pas madame à temps plein sur
les véhicules
presque quatre ans plus tard 2500
personnes vont recevoir une indemnité de
québec variant entre 400 et 1400 dollars
mais si le gouvernement québécois a
accepté une entente à l'amiable
la ville de montréal refuse toujours
d'indemniser les victimes
ici vincent maisonneuve radio canada
montréal